[Music]
there's no shortage of mysteries to be
solved right now in cosmology
how did the universe begin
how is it evolving what is its ultimate
fate
I want to build instruments to explore
parts of the universe that are not seen
yet
I hope that there are surprises waiting
for us
my name is Cynthia Chang I'm an
associate professor in physics at McGill
University and I'm an observational
cosmologist so I build telescopes for a
living one of the wonderful things about
radio astronomy is that we are able to
you know quote unquote see the universe
in ways that we cannot see with our own
eyes if you pick a particular frequency
is you know lower than 1420 megahertz
you can tune into a particular slice of
the universe's history
we think that the Universe began its
life in the Big Bang which happened
about 14 billion years ago that time the
universe was very hot and very dense as
the universe has expanded and it's
cooled down it's transitioned through
different phases
hydrogen is a very special tool for us
in cosmology and the reason why we rely
on it so heavily is because it's the
most abundant element in the universe
and hydrogen is special because it
naturally glows with radio light and we
can use this emission of hydrogen to
kind of map out where it is in the
universe
anytime you look at any object with a
telescope you're kind of seeing that
object in the past because the universe
is expanding the light from the hydrogen
is stretched out or redshifted in
proportion to how far away the hydrogen
is or equivalently how long ago the
light was emitted so the way we can use
radio telescopes to kind of peer back in
time and map out the history of the
universe is by measuring this redshifted
emission from hydrogen
[Music]
the first thing that you need for a
radio telescope is something to receive
the light and so depending on what kind
of instrument you're building that can
either be a reflector like a dish of
some sort that gathers light and then
focuses it onto a receiver or sometimes
in our experiments we just have bare
antennas that sit and look at the sky we
have to bring it down
the radio signals that we're looking for
are typically very faint and so
immediately after you receive that
radiation the first thing that you want
to do is amplify it
and then there's usually digitizing
electronics that turn those analog
signals from the telescope into numbers
that then we can put on the computer
all right go ahead
the reward in doing this work is that by
knowing the science and the kinds of
things that you have to measure that
informs our design so that we're able to
build a machine that's specifically
targeting our goals and then we can
optimize it to our hearts content
it's going to take off climb to 50 feet
and then hover over the antenna okay
then we'll run configure PGA perfect
we'll start up dump base band dump
spectro and send it up to five pack
one of the greatest challenges of
observing in the radio is that there's
all sorts of interference at Radio
wavelengths created by humans FM radio
AM radio TV towers cell phone towers all
sorts of stuff so we often end up in
kind of strange places out in the middle
of nowhere where it's you know quite
literally quiet radio quiet so that we
can get a better view of the sky
the most recent sites that I've worked
at are in the high arctic Northern
Canada and also Marion Island which is
an island in the sub Antarctic it's
located about halfway between South
Africa and Antarctica it's about 2 000
kilometers away from anything else
Marion is windy and it's rainy and it's
cold year round the winds are especially
bad
my team has two experiments that ran
from Marion Island and one of them prism
was designed to be a cosmic Dawn
experiment so specifically looking for
the signature of the first Stars
eliminating in the universe roughly
about 100 million years after the big
bang it's exciting to study because we
basically have no measurements of this
period the experiment consists of two
antennas each about the size of a coffee
table the way the prism antennas work is
that they are basically a very sensitive
thermometers or microphones as you can
think about it they just kind of measure
the average intensity across the entire
sky so we're not trying to make pictures
with these antennas the frequencies that
we're looking at from cosmic Dawn are
actually exactly FM radio that plus a
little bit more so if you can imagine
tuning into all of the radio stations at
the same time with your car radio what
we're listening for is kind of the
static from the early universe but
within that static buried deep within
there for a few of those radio stations
we're listening for where the static is
a little quieter
[Music]
the other experiment that we have set up
is an interferometer that is trying to
map out the low frequency sky as a first
step towards future observations of the
Dark Ages at about 400 000 years after
the big bang that's one of the periods
in the in the most distant history that
we have yet to access and we have zero
measurements of the Dark Ages so far the
universe turned from this glowing
ionized plasma and became transparent
light was created at this point known as
The Cosmic microwave background and
that's sometimes known as the Afterglow
of the Big Bang
in addition to that light being released
the universe became cold enough for the
first neutral hydrogen atoms to form the
hydrogen that was created at that point
was basically all there was in the
universe
the cosmic microwave background gives us
literally a photo of the universe in its
infancy but that snapshot is also
preserved in the distribution of
hydrogen throughout the dark ages one of
the very exciting things is that if we
could one day map out that distribution
of hydrogen in full three dimensions we
could learn you know a huge amount about
our universe
the albatross experiments it's an array
of antennas and these antennas will all
observe together to produce an image of
the sky
the next array that we're going to build
in full is in the high Arctic so when
that's fully operational the antennas
will be spanning about 10-15 kilometers
or so between the ones that are most
distant from each other
our goal with Albatross is to make maps
or take pictures of our Milky Way galaxy
at very low frequencies and to get an
image of the Milky Way that's
significantly sharper
we have to understand our Milky Way
emission before we can subtract it off
and look for the Dark Ages signal behind
it so that that's our very first step is
kind of knowing our enemy before we
fight it then we'll then we'll try to
fight it and get to the cosmology
[Music]
thank you